Speaker 1: . Folks, there is trouble brewing. I
am in very much trouble right now. Glenn Greenwald
and Briahna, Joy Gray are coming for me because
I don't think Marianne Williamson is a good
candidate. Let's back up a little bit. I tweeted
yesterday that I see a lot of. You will see
Gabbard Energy moving towards Marianne Williamson.
There were a bunch of people who fell for Tulsi
in 2020, and now, of course, that she's like an
anti-vaxx Republican CPAC speaker. You know, it's
completely unhinged what's happened with Tulsi.
Some of the Tulsi people have realized, All right,
we've got to get away from Tulsi. Let's go behind
someone else. And so some of that energy is moving
behind Marianne Williamson. Now, I know that in
2020, Glenn Greenwald was at least a casual fan
of Tulsi. I have no idea. On Briahna, Joy Gray
I'm not super familiar whether I think she's
come up once before on the show like a couple of
years ago, but I don't know too much about her.
So we did a segment where I told you, as I always
do, because I'm honest, I'm not going to pretend.
Right. I told you I'm not super impressed with
Marianne Williamson's candidacy. I think she
has every right to run. Anybody who wants to run
should. This is America. She should be able to
present her views. She should run as a Democrat
or as an independent or as a Republican, whatever
she wants. I defend it. I support it. This is
what America is about. And I also mentioned
that personally. It's not for me. Her woo woo
pseudo science background isn't for me. She has
the right ideas on a number of political issues.
But that doesn't mean I would make her president.
She has no experience, she has no expertise,
she has no qualifications, and she has no
sort of understanding of the way politics works.
So might you go to like a Reiki practitioner and
they're like, Hey, I'm for Medicare for All.
Great. Doesn't mean you make them president,
doesn't mean you support them in a primary. But
that's all I was saying. And anybody is free to
do, of course, whatever they want. Glenn
Greenwald didn't like it. Glenn Greenwald
responded to this on Twitter by saying, quote,
Those quotes, Marianne Williamson quotes I read
that sounded like Deepak Chopra. Glenn says
those quotes aren't remotely kooky. They're
reflective of someone engaging the vast mysteries
of life via spirituality and transcendence. But to
utterly conventional midriffs, he's talking about
me, to utterly conventional middleweights serving
as normalcy enforcers. David Pakman anything
beyond New York Times op ed page dreck seems,
quote, crazy. So Glenn doesn't agree with me. And
then Briahna, Joy Gray, who I think is a podcaster
and I guess is in league with some of these
folks, I'm not super familiar with her.
She tweets about this in response to Glenn. Biden
guy wants to vote for Biden again. This is why
part of the left is dead. And it's like, which
are you talking about? The only part of the left
that ever wins, that ever, quite literally, ever
wins. She's saying that part of the left is dead.
The only part that ever wins anything. Oh,
okay. Very interesting. As far as I know,
that tweet was not particularly well received
and Brianna subsequently deleted it. Okay. So
let's again, just make sure we're all on the
same page. Biden wasn't my guy in the primary.
I'm just not delusional. Okay. Marianne Williamson
has no experience relevant to being president of
the United States. If you tell me. Hey, you know
what, David? We have too many, like lawyers.
Who are presidents or business people who
are president. We need people from different
backgrounds. I'm with you. I want scientists as
presidents. I want, you know, people who have led
nonprofits. Would be great for presidents. I would
like to see people from the field of education be
present. There's. Oh, I'm with you. We have
to narrow a scope for people that eventually
become president. But Marianne Williamson has no
relevant experience, no relevant expertise, no
qualifications, and also none of the relationships
that would make you a more effective president.
She's for Medicare for All. That's great. She
believes climate change should be taken seriously.
Great. But she's not going to push Biden to the
left because she's not even going to debate Biden
if Biden runs for reelection. There's not going
to be a real primary. She's not going to debate
Biden. If you came to me and you said David Katie
Porter, oh, now we're talking. Okay, now we're
talking if you said David. Stacey Abrams, not only
an extremely skilled organizer, but deep policy
knowledge and understands the system. Stacey
Abrams Absolutely. But Marianne Williamson is
not for me. So if the sort of followers of people
in the Greenwald universe catch wind of this,
they'll probably come after me pretty hard.
But I'm completely comfortable with that. Bring
it on. This is my view. Marianne Williamson I
support her having a candidacy if that's what
she wants. Gosh darn it, there's nothing more
American than that. But it's just not for me.